I'm Dan V Verner I'm your host for today
and we're really happy to have brad
geddes
join us today for seven skills every
digital marketer needs to succeed so
whether you're new to digital marketing
or working with a marketing team at an
enterprise or you're an entrepreneur the
latest digital marketing skills are
essential in today's fast evolving
digital world in this hour brad geddes
is the digital marketing course advisor
for simply learning well share with us
the essential skills that every digital
marketer needs in order to step up from
being good to great in digital marketing
and then contribute to your
organization's business or career goals
so these include top tools and platforms
and even soft skills that you need to
have in their back pocket so some of
these skills are really essential and
they may surprise you so now I'd like to
just talk about brad geddes he's the
author of advanced Google Adwords and a
co-founder of the award-winning company
a Dallas's an automatic platform for ad
testing and PPC recommendation Brad
frequently writes columns for search
engine land code moderates the AdWords
form on webmaster world
he's also keynoted and spoken at more
than 85 conferences and has led more
than 80 AdWords seminars plus he's a
course advisor like we said before for
simply learning and he's a digital
marketing curriculum advisor here so I
just want to take a moment to welcome
Brad how are you doing good good can you
hear me okay you're coming in just fine
thanks for joining oh thank you for
hosting us so so welcome everyone so
today we're going to look at you know
first how digital marketing fits
together because when you have a job in
digital marketing
arrey ly a silo you're often working at
other team to see how things sort of fit
and how teams interact then looking at
you picking a specialty and then some
critical hard skills the the real change
that must have soft skills and
communication so only look at at an
overall digital marketing funnel it
starts with traffic drivers so traffic
drivers are things like paid search
organic
social emails so that they send traffic
to your site and each one of those is
sort of a separate discipline and then
that funnels to your site and the goal
of the site then of course is to convert
users so that's where conversion
optimization comes into place and of
course if they convert or they give you
some data email whatnot then they go
into your CRM system right which is a
completely different person in large
companies and in small ones this may be
one person doing everything and then
from the CRM system and the website
where you have analytics and say how did
things actually go and then that goes
back into making changes for your
traffic drivers so kind of have this big
circle and so if you think of someone
who is doing CRO well they're getting
traffic right from PPC SEO social email
whatnot right and then they're trying to
convert it so they're going to work up
the funnel a bit if someone who is
working on the analytics well they're
going to look at you know work with
again the PPC SEO social people for what
their data looks like in storytelling
and potentially help with with credit
reports so while these are often write
multiple disciplines someone who
specialized in paid search specialize in
organic or CRO or CRN's or analytics
right there's different interactions
that occur between the groups so we look
at those all those could be trained
skills where you can get training and
SEO you get training and social but we
think about which one is best for you
right this this comes in to essentially
saying what do you really really care
about
right so PPC and social paid social they
have a lot of math and analytics
involved I mean setting bids is math
counting conversions is math doing
revenue is math they have a lot of
creativity involved what's the strategy
what does the ad copy look like so those
two teams will work with most the
departments in some fashion so if you
really like the combination of math and
creativity Oh PPC social ads is a good
fit now we look at social it's
completely different right social as
much what
vacation community engagements um you'll
work with PR branding support and you
might work some with the PVC jeans in
sympathy SEO but not nearly as much as
you will with PR and in support systems
so if you're an extrovert you love
talking to people you look like joining
up community right socials are a good
fit
now we look at SEO no SEO is too broken
down into so essentially three
departments so we've got technical SEO
this means you're looking at page speed
and how the server is rendering pages
right so technical SEO super super
detail-oriented we've spent a lot of
time using tools you spent a lot of time
working with development departments in
some coding is probably going to be
necessary or at least reading code to
understand why something is slow how do
we make our images faster loading etc so
that's a very technical person the next
we have on-site SEO so this is often
creating content making things that are
got a linkable and shareable so that on
site is often going to be much more
again creativity but more of a long-form
creativity then your paint searches
right and some types of watch parties is
necessary but not nearly as much as
straight technical SEO and then we've
got our our link building efforts well
this is going to be the content creation
but viral content creation really good
shareable content creation and then
outreach to tell your people to link
into it so if you like writing and talk
and other people I'll link below might
be a really good fit and so all four of
these it doesn't matter if you're
technical on federal Inc you're going to
work with the content teams to create
content which again could be the same
person development if you're technical
SEO your developments going to look like
server architecture and you know page
speeds we're development on on sites and
say how do we scale title tags across
100 or 10,000 pages or whatnot and then
you need this to convert right that's
the end goal so you're looking to see
our team some now if you're Ciera can
prevent optimization right your goal is
to increase conversion rates from people
driving traffic to the site so you're
going to work with someone a PPC team
some of the SEO teams some of the email
teams because they're sending the
traffic and so they're going to say hey
we're sending traffic to this page is
not converting as well as these others
what can we do what can we test here so
math and analytics again important
because you need to look at all right
which one is actually the best one often
the CRO may also work with the crm team
to make sure data flows correctly CRM so
creativity is much different here right
creativity is necessary but it's more in
ideas to test this individual does not
have to sit down and come up with all
the content they don't to be a great
writer and say hey based on what we've
done in the past we see that using this
layout does better than this layout over
here and maybe the reason is X so let's
try this XY test over here so their
creativity is going to stem from the
interpretation of the math of what
they've seen in test results so some
tech expertise is useful because in many
cases you're going to be using a
third-party tool it could be you know a
visual episode optimizer google
optimized whatnot to help with the
testing so you don't often need to know
how to code but you need to know enough
about how code works so that you can
implement one of these testing tools and
so you'll work with IT on how to
actually implement it then you work
again with the traffic drivers so if you
really like math but you like creativity
from over a platform standpoint right
CRO is a good fit now we look at
analytics right this is obviously full
of math and analytics but that's only
part of this job right the biggest
change in analytics over the past five
years which will continue for the next
100 is data storytelling right
automation and AI is putting a lot of
data
in front that is structured and can
fairly easily be interpreted now the
thing is that's just a big data set and
you look at a big excel sheet it tells
you nothing right so the job of
analytics is to take that huge doubt of
them and make it useful right say this
is the story you learn with it so they
need to be able to be storytellers they
don't have to come up with a story but
the stories there in the math they have
to communicate the story to other teams
and they're going with everybody so at a
top level right and you think okay will
I really want to learn often goes to
what are you really passionate about
right do you love creativity and
influencing people and trying out
different things but you also like not
that PPC you you love engaging with
other people well that's probably more
social so that's really kind of step one
of what skills necessary by discipline
now when we dig into these further right
so PPC you get creativity from an ad
standpoint so text ads obviously and we
can type where where it gets all more
difficult is having photoshop skills or
some design skills is useful in smaller
companies because often a small company
does not have a dedicated designer in a
large company you've got a designer you
say hey we need images look like this
they go make the SS for you smaller ones
having that design skills really useful
any strong math now that's what you go
get trained in right that's your top
whether your PPC now what you need to
know the basics of you don't have to be
the expert but know the basics of CRMs
your CRM is where your lead set and so
you've got a lead you've got a marketing
qualified lead you have a sale right and
so if you don't understand the CRM you
might be tracking leads in reality you
want qualified leads and sales to make
decisions on CRO all right you've got
this guy over here this girl over here
who who works to make the content
convert better well what do you see from
the ads standpoint or from the user cent
standpoint that you can pass along
right and every page there's people
every single one should have at least
analytics 101 to log in my analytic
system and quickly pull their own data
for what the kind of stuff they need now
tertiary these are skills useful but
won't be used heavily right so content
creation right longer story creativity
creating landing pages so this again in
a large company they won't be making
these and a small one they will be SEO
right SEO is often the site design a lot
of SEO teams use paid search to test
title tags there are work but you know
see how different title tags work from
an ad standpoint and roll them out
across on the website sales right how do
you watch qualified leave how do you
build a funnel so that you can see the
drop off is actually not in the
qualified leads it's in the sales
contact rate right and then email a
course like a fall sequence so you know
primary you need to be really good at
secondary have a solid understanding but
don't need to be an expert in tertiary
good to have the 101 level now if we
move to SEO though it's different
great so primary if you're in link
building this content creation and
outreach really good strong email
writing skills to to build links to get
that link to content now if your primary
is link building right then your second
very skills often fit from the the
technical side some analytics were
diagnosis some information on site speed
HTML HD accesses redirect tag management
and so forth if your technical SEO then
obviously the technical side is your
primary right fight speed HTML CSS so
forth in your content creation link
building is secondary tertiary depending
on how many people are in that
department
and then lastly write the SEO s should
have some idea about PPC a 101 level
right keyword research testing title tag
structures so much you think you can
learn for SEO from paid search and then
see our up make sure people convert so
if you love the technical side right but
you want to be more on the website asset
side that's where the tech SEO is really
strong
and you want a good background in now if
we look at social right social is very
different so your primary is
communication whether communication is
images on where the image sharing sites
whether it is text on a site more like
Twitter and so communication is your
number one job you're number two job is
risk management so you need to be
level-headed when something really bad
happens right you just reactor you step
back think about what just happened
probably make it quick called the brand
team and say hey we have this issue
here's ways we can address it you know
what a great example of this is the
Kentucky Fried Chicken they're actually
fantastic at socialness a month ago six
weeks ago or something they ran out of
chicken in England they Kentucky Fried
Chicken hide milking had no chicken they
had signs of the door sorry were out and
so when they came back great they were
like how do we address this rate how do
we assure people that we screwed up it
wasn't them in and they reprinted there
all the buckets that no longer said KFC
they said f ck on them which if you look
at that fold-out you can tell what
they're trying to say if they did went
over fantastically and their sales were
actually higher than before right but
that's math managing risk correctly and
then secondary right design now often in
on a platform like Twitter or Facebook
you want some design skills yourself um
D uh was it Oreo Duncan in the dark from
Super Bowl maybe three four years ago
the lights on Super Bowl they quickly
right maiden made an image put it out
but even when lights are out you can
still you know dunk your Oreos great
response brief so they don't have time
to sit down so we want to do this and
reset design team to create something
and get it back and send it out they eat
it is instantly so some design skills
are really really useful if you're just
on the free social side you all seen a
bit of a creativity intensity
r-right especially the way today looks
at social and then tertiary skills good
to know
email you're going to work at the email
on non sales emails your general
communication analytics you've got
Twitter analytics Facebook analytics
YouTube analytics right so how's it
going to reacting it to you video video
is one of the fastest growing mediums
around so you don't necessarily need to
know a lot about video right now it's
going to be more and more useful as time
goes by on the social side all right now
someone's got to convert this traffic so
we think of CRO right their primary
skills are creativity for testing
analytics to understand how to test to
write secondary content creation they
may need to do some content creation
work with content teams so having a good
writing background is very useful and
they may need design skills but this is
no longer image creation this gets down
to HTML CSS et cetera because they may
not always have the ability to reach out
to get them to make a new page right
away and so if that goes into speed of
corporate culture at times and then
tertiary they should have a basic
understanding of the people they're
converting the traffic for what are the
SEO PPC email social team's actually
doing because I understand what they're
dealing and their audience you can
create the hate is that more likely to
convert right for less traffic drivers
so if you're if you love CRO you don't
have to be a PPC guru but you should
know PPC 101 SEO 101 to make sure you
understand what they're really asking of
you and have a better dialogue back and
forth analytics so you got a lot math if
you're in analytics you have to love
math that's that's pretty much a given
now communication is the fastest-growing
skill among analytics users because
again we need to be able to explain what
the data means you know ten years ago if
you got a report on some big website you
might get a fifty page are so fifty book
sell documents and there are some charts
there are a lot of grass there was a lot
of numbers in the first tab might be a
three paragraph explanation of the 50
charts involved that's no longer
acceptable right now but what they
really want is a word doc explaining
everything or PowerPoint explaining it
with a chart that gives them a visual
idea of how data is changing up and down
so communication is a serious skill for
analytics mode where it wasn't five and
ten years ago lastly an analyst person
should have Java you get 101 to a one
type of skills GA I'll mature a lot of
the tag management systems sit in in a
Java Java code so it's useful to have a
little bit of you know maybe PHP
information so you understand how to
code the Java for a PHP page or if
you're an Azure or whatever happens to
be but you want just a basic level of
coding because a lot of analytics
platforms have almost wrote code base
that goes with it
now secondary CRM because if the data is
here on ascending you is salty then you
can't do a good job so you don't want to
work this here on how exports work how
does that afloat wean the two systems
right and this goes to marketing
automation as well so in analytics your
interpretation is only as good as a data
received I mean that's that's obvious so
you have to be the one to make sure you
are receiving the correct data and sort
of being able to follow the data up and
down the chain so this is why it's also
useful to have some basic information on
PPC SEO email and social to make sure
their traffic is flowing correctly and
also because you're telling stories to
them you want to stick them in their own
language so an analytics person primary
obviously no analytics and math but
should have a basic level the others so
they can tell the correct story so
departments it doesn't matter what you
do you will use this program called
Excel it does not matter
everybody needs know
basic sorting filtering conditional
formatting and make a pivot table
everybody's going to use those skills
now if one of your primary skills is
also math then you need to know pivot
charts regular charts vlookup Nestle
arguments advanced formulas now if your
job is analytics and it may be CRO or
managing large paid search then having
data visualization like power bi and
tableau is also useful to know that's
beyond Excel so we look back to our
chart here what you really want to do is
say I love X I love social I'm talking
to people I love SEO digging into how
site architecture works is fascinating
right you want to find one that you
really like
that's your specialization right that's
where you're going to look at the skills
necessary for that specialization that's
trainable skills then write based upon
how traffic flows to our site we want to
know that the sort of one-on-one level
of these other items because everyone
should be talking to each other so what
happens in companies sometimes is you've
got you know a PPC person who
understands all the other systems and
then you've got an SEO person who
understands SEO and maybe analytics but
doesn't really get the other channels or
the CRO the CRM system and suddenly they
end up until this island they can't get
resources because I don't have talked to
people correctly right and so when
everyone has this basic level there's
much much better communication happens
in companies unless but a collaboration
happens and it makes everyone's job
better and actually makes the whole
digital marketing efforts you know much
better
alright so Nelson a sort of soft skills
things that you are going to use
regardless of your job type number one
is organization that you don't need to
be a known CP certified project manager
but you should have an idea of how
project management works how the systems
out there work whether it's Basecamp
Trello you know JIRA it take your pick
and then how to say Oregon some asset
standpoint a lot of times things are
made assets are created and notice how
to find it so regardless
if your unsocial you're like we had that
great image six months ago that if we
have that again that's it's a perfect
time to recycle that well they don't
have access to the assets because there
are only in the design team and no one
gotta save it or you're seeing email
saying hey you saw the confident image
or you just lost you not spent more time
trying to find it then it's probably
worth in the end and so organization is
good for everybody
logical thinking so AI rights is
something keeps coming up own over again
how's our donation going to take over my
job or how to work with automation so
parse your job you want to automate
there's certain things you just don't
want to do the boring work over and over
and over again now if you can't
flowchart that out for the development
team they can't they can never build it
so having an ability to think through
things logically flowchart skills 101
but you can look at something say okay
this goes here this goes here this
because here if ever get to a point we
say it kind of depends on the situation
what we do can automate it are you going
to think past those sort of steps and
quantify them and so as automation
increases in usage and ai increases in
usage to make sure you can work
appropriately with that sort of change
maybe they'll think logically about how
users flow through whatever your
department is right how data flows and
then what decisions you would make if
you're constantly like and we do it
based upon how we feel like that day
can't be automated right and that's not
going to keep you going well for very
long in the company either when you know
you're you're not be consistent with
what's happened so logit thinking very
useful data visualization so if you're
an analytic CRO PPC data visualization
is really really important but this is
is not that hard of a chart to create
that shows the change in touch points
over time that it's okay user to visit a
site before they convert it so are our
people who came once write the
conversions have dropped significantly
where people are coming 12 times it's
gone ups it's gone quite a bit now to be
able to explain a
very long story like that in one chart
takes little logical thinking of how you
make sense right and so this again this
is just excel in a pivot table and then
a pivot chart off the pivot table so I
don't know five six minutes in total to
you know I agree at the data and create
but this is the kind of charts very more
more common so number one yet to not
create it too perhaps you'll to
interpret it which is also why
understanding the basics of Excel and
Excel charts is useful because then you
can say okay I know how this is made so
I can you know if I don't understand it
reverse-engineer it so I can actually
fear of the story is no again I said a I
don't doesn't I'm so far we won't say it
too many more times but what AI does not
have where humans win is empathy or
humans are creative humans have empathy
and so when you think about talking with
customers getting stuff done in
different teams how you explain to your
boss why you need more funding for a new
project or are you thinking okay what do
people want what do people avoid and how
do we frame this right positioning so
that we get what we want and so as
computers do more and more what they
lack is empathy
nothing is computers aren't buying from
computers on large scale right now
humans are buying from humans the
computers are an intermediary that we
can sort of get our stuff from one spot
to the next and so that that empathy is
going to be incredibly important going
forward as soft skills communication
empathy creative thinking are more
valued because a lot of basic math can
be automated you have to know how to do
the math so you understand what's being
automated so you can change the
automation right that that's important
like an analytics arrow standpoint but
when it comes to to the storytelling
part getting funding team communication
right that's where empathy is really
important now platforms change all the
time Google starts consoles is going
through the midst of a change right now
Google AdWords has a brand new interface
which it wasn't there a year and a half
ago and it's still changing Google
Analytics updates its UI gosh every six
months they seem to move something
around again and so if you learn how to
push buttons you're not going to have a
job when the buttons change you know my
in my very first company I built myself
I hired my first employee in 1998 1999 I
forget which and I was I was an SEO
person back then I was doing that paid
to but paid was pretty small at that
point in time and with the old search
engines excited AltaVista so forth if
two sites high because you could tie for
the number one spot if two sites were
tied the last site crawled was put in
every one position so I hired people
whose jobs was to put in a URL into a
search engine and hit submit
right now I had a few people doing this
because it was actually worth it to pay
them to do this from our game standpoint
and then Windows 2000 came out natively
had macros supported macros in it I
could replace every button pusher with a
macro so that's the problem if you just
push button a than B's and C you can be
automated now right so we want to know
is concept where we have to know how to
push buttons but we need to know the
concepts of why we push the button so
when the button change or the button has
a slightly different thing it does once
it's pushed you understand that nuance
difference to either decide which new
button to push or explain to someone
else in the company or clauncher what
not the option so they can make a good
decision right and this is a very
important part of learning is to
understand the concept behind the idea
right that ID itself and not just yeah I
go I login I hit this I hit this I hit
this I hit this then I go to the other
system and I hit this this and this
export I send it off well if that's your
job like you probably shouldn't have one
right so you need to know we
do this first because we need this right
that's like context that's necessary to
be able to adapt as platforms change as
market conditions change as your
customer type changes so in the office
during business hours we spend 70 to 80
percent of our day communicating with
other people so that's right little
Orbitz reading a lot more of it speaking
and the vast majority is listening you
think give an hour-long meeting there
are four people in the meeting assuming
no one talks at the same time right in
is equal distribution you spent 15
minutes speaking in 45 minutes listening
during that hour right so critical
listening skill
what are they saying and what do they
mean to say are really really important
communication is going to be one of the
top skills going forward that's how we
talk your website is a communication
method is persuading users to take an
action you're on average the average
person spends 40 40 business emails per
day right that's a lot of time reading
writing just emails outside of meetings
and clients everything else
communications are really big one now a
subset of communication is persuasion
that can be persuasion exhaust so takes
for a positioning into account there to
your persuasion is how we how we get
someone to take some sort of action and
in positioning is how do we show our
part against a different product for a
competitor right that makes ours look
attract and so advertising right is
essentially all about persuading users
to take action so this is involved in
every part of the digital marketing
ecosystem organic title tags right
that's an ad design and get something to
click on Todd had to go to website your
PPC ad does the same thing your social
ad does the same thing great your email
does the same thing
they put out a message that says go here
to learn X now then you're conned on the
website is answering X and if you're a
publisher you're making money off the
ads but if you're an advertiser right
it's persuading user on site to do next
action Add to Cart call us download
white paper and
the majority of the job outside of
analytics because that's more reporting
side a sort of analytics the majority of
people's jobs in digital marketing is
all around persuasion how do you
persuade convince someone to take an
action and so communications a global
thing is very important but subsets of
persuasion and positioning are also
incredibly important throughout digital
marketing so when we look at an AI
powered world and McKenzie did a big
study right that said how are people's
hours going to change we now in 2030 so
the next you know 12 years so it's okay
hours spent physical manual skills
they're going to decrease of course
going to decrease this is why factories
get automation boundaries are going out
of business I mean there's is a big
reason automation taking manual skill
jobs basic cognitive skills so one plus
one right to the basic skill that's
that's automated now we don't do simple
math and we sit and do most of our day
right you don't look at analytics and
can up your hits by different sites to
give a number of hits and say okay but
hits is actually not unique users and do
the math for this right so that basic
cognitive skill decreasing rote memory
BOTS are going to take over you know you
call in you read a script right that's
just reading a script a bot can do that
so those skills are under decline now
higher cognitive skills right doing
algebra trigonometry in depth writing
persuading write data storytelling they
require multi facets of the brain to
work together those are going to
increase in usage over time and that
sort of our change that we could see
from AI from the from the learner from
the the basic cognitive skills which was
sort of like the pre ATM days rate to a
CMS took over paint colors actually were
hired in more I'm not moreover hired not
less to ATMs and that was because they
needed high
skills what mortgage is best for you
rate in some way went from a deposit
right to a mortgage and they switch
cognitive skills with that big info
Revolution in the 70s said to 2000s it's
slowing down now but it's not going to
stop biggest second biggest change
social and emotional skills all right
this is what computers can't do AI
cannot empathize with somebody you can
program it to give an empathetic
response but if you're talking to
someone you know it's that you've all
seen an email or a script like that was
pre-written doesn't matter how good it
was pre-written you're like yep they
just sent me the foreign letter right so
that that social and emotional skill is
definitely going to increase and those
again fall under that communication
umbrella and of course the largest
increase is tech skills whether your
program machine odd in the machine
deciding what the Machine can audit can
automate so forth that'll be the biggest
difference is the straight tack but from
a soft skill standpoint social and
emotional is incredibly important and so
when you look at studies from McKinsey
look at studies from Microsoft look at
studies from LinkedIn did a big study
and say what are the skills truly
necessary right
storytelling creativity persuasion those
are the three most important soft skills
now you have to know those across spoken
written and video video being being the
newest one and how do you really look on
camera and and while you know this was a
top three skills across the board no but
kenzie looked at all this and said well
in reality all of this just boils back
down to communication right
communication being the the number one
increasing skill to know right to be
able to communicate the persuasion and
an ad to data storytelling from
analytics person right persuasion
communication communication is essential
AI can do a lot
doesn't understand context right so what
humans can do they could say okay the
marketing editions change this way we
did this our users changeable but this
way here's the new way we should address
this communicate that up and down the
ladder then have a new message write the
new communication message and push that
new communication message out to users
so they can read it right this is a big
skill now that the issue is right you
got out what you're talking about
so AI is can do a lot right but hard
skills know what the machine is doing
the understand what's happening they
they know how to change it or audit it
now they don't know the code right I
don't know how to how to program an AI
machine but I can look and say it's
making bad decisions here right this is
the problem AI team you go working in
fix on this hard skills mean you know
what you're doing right now that means
you know what you're doing soft skills
means you prove you can prove you know
what you're doing right I've seen
employees who were amazing at their job
but they had no way of showing they were
amazing so they would do if you looked
at the stats from the productivity of
the Department of something they were
off the charts but they couldn't tell
you what they were good or why they were
bad right they couldn't prove it and
then I want that employee who was very
edges average the average worker he was
the number one rated person in our
organic team by clients and it was
because he had great soft skills doesn't
have very average SEO but would talk to
clients listen to them you know talk to
the problems come up with some kind of
solution while it was good or not didn't
matter right to get amazing listening
skills and so hard skills means don't
you're doing but men always get you
promoted right they get you your your
job right though you keep your job but
your soft skills prove you know doing
your hard skills and that's what
advancement comes from sort of time kind
of recap right take a specialty what are
you passionate about
is it melding mapping creativity is it
big ideas for a website
right is it communication with other
individuals pick especially right then
you want to enhance that right
communication Excel organizations
storytelling persuasion logical thinking
then right you want to grow why don't
learn the basics of your complementary
specialties so if you're in PPC all
right you're going to know CRO analytics
next then maybe learn the basics of SEO
and so that's really how you pick a
place to really get a job prove you know
what you're doing right so you can grow
your job and enhance that and then learn
the other basics so that you can
actually move up in the company to look
across different departments all right
so with that I'm going to hand it back
to to Dan for am moment so recant just a
couple more things great fantastic
well thinks that before we before we
start recapping some of these things I
also want to open the floor up to even
more questions we actually have a quite
a few questions right now and let me
start and fire those off to you now Brad
if you're ready to go so the we have a
couple questions that are that are
similar and they have to do with ways
that markers can kind of keep track of
the the latest changes and all their
tools like as things are changing in in
in different software or things are
coming down the pike how can how can
marketers keep their ear to the rail as
to what's happening on the tools side
are there other blogs or other
particular people to follow I was a big
google reader person like the the reader
their RSS reader and now I use feedly
because every one of these has a blog
and not just on the blog posts or stuff
motion lover new features and so that
way I've actually got one call I think
one X holder or something which is you
know the tools we use connected to the
blogs and then if they don't have RSS
which is rare but then they get an email
so we automate that RSS that they email
RSS which is actually not that too
difficult so I've got one place to look
into quickly scan out of new changes
that's how I personally do is I find if
you just rely on them sending emails all
the time
you
or too busy looking at emails for work
that you often just ignore the other
ones and you only like yeah that's why
open rates like if you get a thirst note
for you doing great so it's easy to miss
those where our assess usually in mind
for me at least works best emails best
for you use that but yeah it's going to
be in our accessory email or something
okay great the similar question was so
was asking about research there's
there's a lot of research out there on a
be testing and best practices and in
addition to of course subscribing to
similar in webinars so that you can keep
on top of all of our webinars and best
practices and and their resources tools
resources as well what are some ways
that people can track the ad tests and
best practices of all the email SEO web
design things like that it's so again
last session yeah that's kind of finding
your your favorite places to get content
right so you can either again I mean
there's Twitter aggregate stuff or you
can go and you know have Twitter do a
search for topic and then aggregate that
information and send you the top likes
or retweets or whatever I'm useful for
if you're talking about but net might
always be um the best if you have
certain people you you really enjoy
alright then most of them have some
blogs some results some you know
something or they're publishing studies
or doing this or that you can subscribe
to them um I get I like RSS but you know
if you before email or Facebook or
whatnot there's Facebook groups for
every topic in the world
there's LinkedIn groups for every
business topic and Beyond around so
finding groups like that's also a good
play to see what the newest things that
are being talked about
yeah great that's a Google user friend
the very least you could type up the
latest testing things another was an
organization called
there's some organizations out there
that actually do a/b testing all the
time and you can find those online like
behave org and another question is how
do you talk about how one of the top
three skills is creativity
how does someone learn creativity that
is a fantastic question right so usually
when you think of creativity as a whole
start with the easier things to do which
is like a creative writing class right
come up with new ideas to write
something as it kind of gets the you
know those those brain juices fooling
initially then right in in our industry
it's all about testing right whether
it's ads or this or that
so we're often looking to see how do dis
de Rais work so do some competitive
analysis get an idea what others are
doing right think through why are they
doing it that way right do the critical
analysis yourself and then do some
testing for yourself and as you do more
and more testing you'll start to put
some pieces together of how things fit
which then gives you ideas for new
things to try again on that creative
side if you need to do it on your feet
go Toastmasters which I know is public
speaking but again it's creativity in
you know watching how people body
position and what they're saying or take
a you know committee um speaking 101
class if you got what is called in
college those are our good ways to kind
of you know get those basic creative
juices sort of flowing but there's no
class it's like become creative
overnight right that's it's it's more of
an ambiguous ambiguous concept but you
can train it yeah there are certain
there are other classes so either
recommend taking improv courses or
classes on the weekends or other groups
like that because all the things it does
is it teaches you games and new ways of
thinking like games this is like a three
word story and bye-bye sometimes people
say you can't teach talent you can't
teach creativity necessarily but if you
learn enough tools you open your mind
into new ways just as you're saying that
you can think about things just was the
the Toastmasters or the the speech class
that can help you improv teachers use
some interesting games that that not
only helps you communicate and listen to
other people
which of course are fantastic soft
skills that you mentioned but also gives
you practice in coming up with ideas and
one the best way to get good at coming
up with ideas is do practice coming up
with ideas outside of work with reading
read yeah we just read 20 minutes
nonfiction non-business books find a
fiction genre you like rate can be short
stories because every book is got a
hundred creative ideas right this lets
you start sort of thinking about things
as well yeah so Shauna is asking how do
you think that high schools could better
prepare people to develop higher order
skills at the next stage what what do
you think colleges need to do better to
develop talent for digital marketing
roles so let's drop it back on the
Accademia wow that's an interesting
question from a high school perspective
right that's that's we're seeing I mean
I live in an area where there's some
just fantastic high schools so they're
learning excel in seventh grade they're
you know they're doing a whole they're
doing
you know usually trigonometry by tenth
grade 11th grade the latest so they're
learning a lot of those basic skills now
when you get into high schools a big
place obviously um you know other places
right what's what's missing is often
real-world application this is where you
know my daughter sometimes will come
home like we're learning this today and
this doesn't seem like there's any
purple never ate this again right it's
like okay you know what is the actual
real-world application for what you're
learning especially in math and that can
often set context of why people need to
learn certain things now in college
that's often just you know how
curriculums are built and so there are
digital marketing curriculums in college
a lot of them have you know bachelor
science degrees that sort of have an
expansion here and there but I think AI
is still so new it takes colleges what
15 20 years to really change and adopt
new things outside of like the master's
class is usually adopted very very
quickly but the
be abs usually much slower on after
thing without one if we were going to
college let me know that would be an
interesting on we get to actually think
about yeah via someone else is asking a
question about how to increase
communications goes but I think that
your you hit it on the nose with going
Toastmasters and taking classes like
that I've heard I've never taken improv
I've heard a lot of speakers and who
like disappeared for six months and came
back much better in they it was improv
classes looking something on the feet
way better and that's actually been
highly recommended for for even people
who have to do presentations in a
company is to go take an improv class
I've heard wonderful things about it
yeah I guess it could certainly help you
think fast on your feet too so here's a
question is there difference between
skills that would be needed in agencies
versus corporate marketing or are is
what you've said so far today blanket
across both things or is there one thing
that stands out one over the other so
they're both just as important they'll
be used differently right so
communication right which again is one
of those global aggregate skills but in
within a company right you're you're
communicating how this affects other
departments and how it influences
different places to come up with new
solutions or new ways of thinking about
how your customers are reacting in
agencies this is often coming on for
more of a data storage have a reporting
standpoint so that you know you don't
fire them right which is the smaller
agency and the larger ones right you're
your full service agencies often need to
also be maybe doing TV or print or
something you know there are much more
collaborative so that actually is more
like the being in-house communication
than than the agency communication but
so the skills are all the same the way
you're going to use them is it will be
different though it's a it is every
fantastic digital every is a two-song of
a word but many really good digital
marketers are they're better if they
spend at least a year in house then a
year at an agency doesn't matter where
they go after that because they
understand the other side and how it
works
increases that empathy side
significantly because you uneven walk
them on their shoes already great yeah
we have a lot of people asking questions
about where they can get special
training courses certification from good
Institute's for example in in India or
the USA we even have someone whose wants
to get an mba in the united states i
know that we can't necessarily go in the
record for recommendations but do you
have any ideas about how people might be
able to find the best schools for them
whether it's in whether it's local to
them or offshore or even online well
obviously we offer a whole lot of them
but it's not we with specific master's
degree on i'm on more likely to look for
universities that understand digital and
support it in some manner now that i
know it's a very vague statement so dom
check Google online marketing challenge
is a program Google has where high
school students are sorry college
students and find a local business
Google gives them x1 of money and they
compete for who builds the best AdWords
account so if you go to a college and
they're not in ghampshire
they're probably not staying abreast of
the the newest latest things that are
happening i you know i do some work with
with penn state on occasion because they
have a professor there who not only is
i've been a top ten transfer Gump ship
for many years but um does a lot with
pew research as well and so they they
work with pew on changing customer
trends in digital marketing so they have
a brand new idea of how everything is
going on and they stay abreast of those
trends so that's one of the things i
would look at in a university is are
they just taking something and just hey
here's what it is or do they have you
know professors and course advisors and
so forth who are doing something more in
the world real world application as
opposed to you know just hiding behind
so that the chalkboard per say right and
and of course for that we also have
another
a lot of schools like Duke continuing
education offers online courses that in
simplement even assist was with that as
well and Duke is a one of the top ten
schools in the United States so that's a
that's worth a worth looking into but of
course in terms of certifications I mean
all these things simply learn training
can can help you get the certifications
that really help you stand out like that
and those certifications as you know
will help you get a much higher salary
we have a couple people asking about
salaries in various countries for
starting in digital marketing and a lot
of information is available on like
salary calm or other sources on the web
you can google the typical digital
marketing or whatever role you you would
like to fit into and find out what the
salary is near you it's very location
specific sentences so there's completely
different starting level then then other
parts of the country or even other parts
of the world so so looking those up on
your own will will help a lot too we
have one question that is on obviously
from an employer asking how what are
some good ways that you can test
candidates for these essential skills ah
that's a great question so a if you do
not if you have someone in-house right
who has that skill you're hiring a good
junior member of that team obviously
have them ask very very specific
questions right it's like I only want to
develop or hire develop um very sick
questions what they know to give them
the you know the Google AdWords tasks or
the you know their various tasks you can
give them to see what they score right
take the simple learn tasks what's
what's their score right now is a way to
do it's very hard to hire someone for a
skill you you don't possess yourself
because there's not a really good way of
sort of seeing their ability right there
you know there's soft skill how will
they communicate they think they can do
their ability launch you know the
ability there are also companies who
will help you the interview process in
digital marketing to ask those correct
questions and so if you've got
someone you know who works a local
agency or another company you mean bring
them in on the interview just to sort of
ask those more pointed questions but be
very specific and ask the follow-up
right so like even in you know in Google
right there's no right or wrong answers
here but like in paid search law Suleman
what's your favorite bid method and
there's this about five or six different
overall bid methods and then why is that
your favorite now the fate their
favorite doesn't tell me anything right
it's the why that tells me everything I
need to know because they thought there
would are the two lays and they pick the
easiest option and so that quick
follow-up to me really useful to
understand their concept learning of
that particular item great well thanks
very much those are all some wonderful
ideas and thanks everyone for all these
questions we are wrapping it up right
now but please if you have any
additional questions feel free to reach
out to us
I just like to you can either reply to
to us at you can or you can contact us
on twitter at simply learn and also you
can contact brad geddes so i just want
to say thanks again bread for joining us
but those of you who registered through
WebEx keep an eye out for follow-up
emails in a week or so that will have a
written rap off of this webinar will
even have a video and more and of course
remember to follow brad on twitter at BG
theory for even more information on PPC
best practices and other digital
marketing ideas but if you have any
other further questions like i said that
didn't get addressed during today's
presentation just tweet us it's simply
at signal earn and we can get back to or
a simple reply to the email that you
receive in your WebEx and we can send
that on to you again Thank You Brad for
all these fantastic ideas thank you Dan
for hosting us along your bet and thank
you again everyone for joining us we'll
see you next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here